sometimes a great film tanks at the box
office but that doesn't make it any less
great today we're presenting some of the
most underrated films of 2020 so far
don't let these future cult classics fly
under your radar also some mild spoilers
ahead so proceed with caution guns
akimbo is a gory black comedy with one
hell of a premise
Daniel Radcliffe plays Myles a
mild-mannered geek who finds himself
forced into a gladiator match did we
mention the guns screwed into his hands
because we meant to you help me I have
guns both into my hands packed with
over-the-top action sequences and
juvenile humor guns akimbo certainly
doesn't take itself too seriously if
you're looking for mindless
entertainment with plenty of action and
lots of laughs guns akimbo might just
blow you away actress Alison Brie best
known for her performance and community
really gets a chance to show off her
acting chops in horse-girl it's a film
she co-wrote using her own family's
history of mental illness as a framework
when we first meet Sarah played by Bree
the film feels light and funny she
definitely seems a bit socially awkward
and she strangely fixated on a local
horse I just haven't been sleeping very
well that's too bad yeah I've been
having like really weird dreams as the
film progresses things take a decidedly
dark turn we learned that Sarah suffers
from wild delusions she's a passionate
student of conspiracy theories belief
she may be a time traveler and rants
about alien abductions horse-girl is an
empathetic look at mental illness
through the lens of a character who
feels achingly real ordinary love is an
unusually affecting film the story
revolves around Tom and Joan a couple in
their 60s played by meum Leeson and
Lesley Manville their lives instantly
become more complicated when Joan finds
a lump on one of her breasts what's
gonna happen Chronicle cancer
there's no point in singing like that we
follow the couple through John's
treatment and watch as their
relationship is put to the ultimate test
it's definitely not an easy watch but
Neeson and Manville both turn in
powerhouse performances the
psychological thriller swallow has a
deeply bizarre premise Haley Bennett
plays hunter a young woman who recently
married into a wealthy family for some
strange reason she suddenly finds
herself obsessed with swallowing and
adamite objects cut off from the rest of
the world and her husband's
well-appointed home hunter first caves
to her odd compulsion by swallowing a
marble as the story progresses we come
to understand more and more about
hunters strange habit swallow can be a
difficult film to watch but it's a bold
and powerful movie that's unlike
anything you've seen before think you've
seen enough Nicolas Cage films think
again the freaky sci-fi horror film
color out of space is one hell of a
movie based on a 1927 short story by HP
Lovecraft the film follows a loving
family that's just moved to an idyllic
home in Massachusetts things start
getting interesting when a meteorite
crashes nearby
needless to say both humans and animals
undergo some horrific physical
transformations over the course of the
film cages over-the-top style is
actually perfectly suited to this McCobb
tale of mayhem and madness
believe me now
[Music]
if you're looking for a genre exercise
that dials the intensity up to 11 you'll
definitely want to give this film a shot
birds of prey was the first big-budget
superhero movie of 2020 but it didn't
exactly set the world on fire Margot
Robbie reprises her role from the 2016
film Suicide Squad once again playing
the unpredictable Harley Quinn
sadly birds of prey failed to rake in
the kind of dough that studios expect to
make from comic-book adaptations it
didn't exactly flop but it certainly
didn't bring in Marvel money either
wondering what birds-of-prey is about
after splitting up with the Joker Harley
decides to make her own way in the world
needless to say things get gritty when
the rest of Gotham learns she's no
longer protected by the Clown Prince of
Crime expect lots of explosions
psychologically speaking vengeance
rarely brings the catharsis we hope for
yeah though it's struggled at the box
office
birds of prey is really quite an
action-packed thrill ride it'd be a
shame to miss this one
in VF w Stephen Lang plays Fred a
Vietnam vet who holds court with his
buddies at the rundown VFW hall
meanwhile the teens and tweens of Fred's
town have been seduced by a deadly new
drug called hype which transforms users
into punk rock mutants before long the
assembled veterans are battling the
oncoming horde with everything they've
got
if you're looking for a self-aware goofy
gorefest VFW should be just the ticket
don't be fooled by how the trailer looks
Saint Francis is an extremely
unconventional comedy Kelley O'Sullivan
plays Bridget a 34 year old woman who
really doesn't know what she wants to do
with her life
she soon hires herself out as a nanny
not because of any personal affinity for
children but because she desperately
needs work soon enough she becomes the
caretaker for young Francis played by
Ramona
Edith Williams the experience forces
Bridget to mature and perhaps even
teaches her a few things along the way
sounds like a light comedy right well
the screenplay which O'Sullivan wrote
bravely tackles some rather sensitive
subject matter with an honesty you
rarely see on the big screen it's
definitely worth a look check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV show
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]